- [Voiceover] Anytime you're trying
to come up with a
mechanism for a reaction,
it's worthwhile to study
a little bit of what
you are starting with
and then thinking about
what you finish with and
think about what is different.
So what we're starting
with, we could call this
one, two, three, four, five,
so this is, let's see,
we have methyl group on
the number two carbon,
it is a pentene, and that
is double-bond between
the number two and number three carbons,
so this is two-methyl-pent-2-ene.
So that's what we start with,
we're in the presence,
we're in an acidic environment,
we've got what's gonna be
catalyzed by our hydronium here,
and we end up with this,
and how is our product
different from what we started with?
Well the double bond is now gone,
the number three carbon
gains this hydrogen,
and now the number two carbon
gains a hydroxyl group.
So one way to think about this is,
in the presence of an
acid, it's acid-catalyzed,
we have gained two
hydrogens and an oxygen,
which is what we've gained,
what could be used to make a water.
And this is actually called an
acid-catalyzed addition of water.
The water isn't sitting on
one part of the molecule,
but if you take the hydrogen we added,
and the hydroxyl we added,
if you combine them,
that's what you need to make a water.
So let's think about how we can,
how this actually happens in
the presence of our hydronium.
So let me redraw this
molecule right over here.
So we copy and paste it, so
that's not exactly it yet,
that is just with the single bond.
So let me draw, woops, wrong tool.
Let me draw the double bond there.
And now let me put it in the
presence of some hydronium.
Alright, so we have an oxygen bonded, two.
So this would just be water,
as oxygen has two lone pairs,
but hydronium is a situation where oxygen
is sharing one of those lone
pairs with a hydrogen proton,
thus making the entire molecule positive,
because the hydrogen proton is positive.
So there you go, this now
has a positive charge.
And this can be pretty reactive,
'cause we know that oxygen
is quite electronegative, it
lives to keep its electrons.
So what is there was a
way, what if there's a way
for the oxygen to take back
the electrons in this bond
right over here, the two
electrons in this bond.
Well what if one of these carbons,
especially the ones that
have the double bonds,
what if some of the electrons
from this double bond
could be used to snab, to
take that hydrogen proton,
and then oxygen can hog
its electrons again.
And you might say, "oh that's reasonable,
but which of these carbons
would actually do it?"
And to think about which of
those carbons would do it,
we have to turn to Markovnikov's rule.
Markovnikov's rule tells us that, look,
if you have a reaction like
this, and alkene reaction,
the carbon that already
has, that's already attached
to more hydrogens is more
likely to gain more hydrogens,
the carbon that's attached
to more functional groups
is more likely to gain
more functional groups.
Another way to think
about it is think about,
well that is the order of the carbons?
Because the higher order of carbon,
the more stable it will be if
it forms some type of cation.
So if you look at this
carbon right over here,
our number two carbon, let me circle it,
our number two carbon is bonded
to one, two, three carbons.
So this is a tertiary carbon.
This one right over here,
this carbon on the other
side of the double bond
is only bonded to one, two carbons.
So this is a secondary carbon.
So the tertiary carbon is
going to be more stable
as a carbocation, you can think of it
as it can spread the charge a little bit.
So it would be more likely
to lose the electrons
in one of these, in one of these bonds,
and so the way that we can
think about this mechanism,
and it might be a little bit clearer
when we form the
carbocation, is let's have,
going to do this in blue.
Let's have these two
electrons that form this bond,
well now they form a
bond with that hydrogen,
and now the oxygen can take
back these two electrons,
and what are we going,
what is going to result?
And I'm drawing it in equilibrium,
remember all of these things
are going back and forth
depending on how things
bump into each other,
but what are we left with?
So let me copy and paste this again
and I'm copying and pasting
in a way that, just so I,
this is the backbone, and
I'll add what I need to add.
So once this happens, we have this carbon,
the number three carbon, now,
woops I keep using the wrong tool.
The number three carbon now
forms a bond with this hydrogen
just like that.
This carbon, our number two carbon,
has lost an electron, it's
no longer sharing this bond.
And so now it is going to
have a positive charge,
it is a carbocation and once again
is a tertiary carbocation,
it is bonded to one, two, three carbons.
That is stable, more stable
than if we did it the other way
around, if this one grabbed
the hydrogen somehow,
then this would be a
secondary carbocation,
it'd be harder for it to spread
that positive charge around.
And what about our, what
about our molecule up here?
Let's see what it looks like now.
We have our oxygen bonded
to the two hydrogens,
it had one of those lone pairs,
and now the electrons in this bond
are now going to form another lone pair.
So it took back an electron,
or you can think of it, it
gave away a hydrogen proton.
And so this is now just neutral water,
and we see that we have a
conservation of charge here,
this was positive in charge,
now our original molecule
is positively charged.
And what feels good about
this is we're getting,
we're getting close to our end product,
at least on our number
three carbon, we now have,
we now have this hydrogen.
Now we need to think about,
well how do we get a hydroxyl
group added right over here?
Well we have all this water,
we have all this water
floating around, let me,
I could use this water
molecule but the odds of it
being the exact same water
molecule, we don't know.
But there's all sorts of water molecules,
we're in an aqueous solution,
so let me draw another
water molecule here.
So the water molecules are all equivalent,
but let me draw another
water molecule here.
And you can imagine, if they
just bump into each other
in just the right way, this is,
water is a polar molecule, it has a
partially negative end near the oxygen
because the oxygen likes
to hog the electrons,
and then you have a partial
positive end near the hydrogens
'cause they get their electrons hogged,
so you can imagine the
oxygen end might be attracted
to this tertiary carbocation,
and so just bumping it
in just the right way,
it might form a bond.
So let me say these two
electrons right over here,
let's say they form a bond
with this, with that number two
carbon, and then what is going to result?
So let me draw, so what is, what is
going to result, let me
scroll down a little bit,
and let me paste, whoops,
let me copy and paste our
original molecule again.
So, here we go.
So what could happen?
This is the one we constructed actually,
so we have the hydrogen there.
We have the hydrogen, now this character,
so we have the water molecule,
so oxygen bonded to two hydrogens,
you have this one lone
pair that isn't reacting,
but then you have the lone
pair that does do the reacting.
And so it now forms a bond.
Woops, let me do it in that orange color.
It now, it now forms an actual bond.
And we're really close
to our final product,
we have our hydrogen on
the number three carbon,
we have more than we want
on our number two carbon,
we just want a hydroxyl group,
now we have a whole water
bonded to the carbon.
So somehow we have to get
one of these other hydrogens
swiped off of it, well that could happen
with just another water molecule.
So let's draw that.
So another water molecule someplace,
I'll do the different color
just to differentiate,
although as we know water, well
it's hard to see what color
is water if you're looking
at the molecular scale.
So here we go, and we're really
in the home stretch at this point.
You have another water molecule,
let's say, let me pick a color.
So let's say these
electrons right over here,
maybe they form a bond
with that hydrogen proton,
and then these, the electrons
in that bond can go back
to form a lone pair on that oxygen,
and then what are we left with?
And this really is the home stretch.
So we are in equilibrium with,
so let me draw my five carbons,
so let's see, I have...
H3C, carbon, carbon, CH2, CH3,
I have a CH3, I say H3C instead of CH3,
I wrote it that way just so
it's clear that the carbons
are bonded to the carbons,
you have the original
hydrogen right over there,
you have the one that we just added
as part of this mechanism,
you have this orange bond
to now, this hydroxyl group,
the hydroxyl group, and it
had one lone pair before,
it had one lone pair
before, but bound to both
of the electrons from this
bond to form another lone pair.
To form another lone pair,
which I am depicting in pink,
and then this water is now,
this water molecule is
now a hydronium molecule.
So let me draw that, so this is now,
oxygen, hydrogen, had one
lone pair that didn't react,
and it had one lone pair that I put
in blue that is reacting
with this hydrogen proton.
With that hydrogen, just like this,
and so since it got the
hydrogen proton it's giving its,
sharing its electrons now,
now this has a positive,
this has a positive
charge, just like that.
I have to be very careful,
in the last step I forgot
to draw the positive charge!
We always wanna make sure that your charge
is being conserved, we started
off with the positive charge
on the hydronium, then we
have the positive charge
on the tertiary carbocation
right over here on our number two carbon,
and now we have the positive charge,
would be right over here,
because that oxygen,
what we saw before that oxygen,
which this water molecule was neutral,
but you could say, you could view it is
"well now it's going to be,
it's now sharing these two electrons
instead of keeping them,"
so you can view it is maybe
it's giving away an electron,
and so now it becomes positive.
And then, and then the positive charge
finally gets transferred to
that other water molecule
when it becomes hydronium.
But just like that we are done.
We have added a hydroxyl
group and a hydrogen combined,
that's a water, so that's why
we call it addition of water,
and it was catalyzed by acid,
so it's an acid-catalyzed
addition of water.